good morning believe nation today's
messages have great expectations over to
you Rick Rubin a lot of the job also is
the expectation it's like setting up an
expectation that we really can make a
great Black Sabbath record that stands
alongside their best work I can remember
having a conversation with Johnny Cash
saying on their first album saying we're
gonna make the best album you ever made
and he looked at me like I was insane
like like how like how could even think
that way he felt like he hadn't made a
good record in probably 25 years and had
been discarded you know at the time that
I met him he was playing at dinner
theatres and had been dropped from two
labels and nobody cared so the idea of
shifting that reframing the experience
to not not just well let's just get in
it let's just do an album but let's do
whatever it takes for it to be the best
album you've ever made what would that
sound like how would that work how much
work would go into it are you willing to
commit to that yeah it's because it's
not easy and some are just don't like it
and and I've worked with some aren't
sure it hasn't worked out where they
just are not willing to do the work
there's a great line from Henry Ford
that goes something like whether you
believe that it's true or not you're
right and I think you live up to your
own expectations whatever you think that
you can become whatever you think that
you can build that's what you're gonna
actually end up building if you're
starting the company and you think you
can only get to here that's where you're
gonna end up and you see a lot of
companies and a lot of entrepreneurs
plateau because of their limited view of
what they think they can accomplish when
I took over this business
Toronto dance Austin we've had a track
record of you know how big the company
has grown and when I brought Alex on
board to help me run the company and be
in charge of operations his immediate
initial goal was to get to the best year
that we've ever had
and that's where he sees the business
boiling that's nothing compared to what
I want to build right I want to build a
business that people want to fly into to
come and see I want to build a business
where Kanye West wants to come and take
a lesson I want to build a business
that's written up in newspapers and
magazines and its featured on YouTube
channels right I have this vision for
what I want to create and I believe that
that's possible and so I am going to
will that into existence and because I
have these great expectations I'm gonna
make that happen where you take somebody
else and put them in the same role and
they might do the logical thing the safe
thing the smart thing and not have great
expectations and then you'll see the
difference right that the person who has
the big vision and believes it and has
the expectations there can accomplish
way more then the person who doesn't but
you always end up reaching the potential
that you think you have and if you keep
beating yourself down and think that you
can't do something great then you never
will
it starts with belief I'm writing a book
right now I've talked about it on this
on the channel and made a series of it
and I want it to be one of the greatest
business books of all time that's my
intention that's my expectation that's
what I'm working so hard to create every
week I think it's easy to mail it in I
think a lot of entrepreneurs mail it in
writing that's good enough
you know it's far and you send it it's
okay and I could have mailed in the book
right I could have I could have made it
an okay book I could have taken some
lessons in the YouTube channel and I
could have been done six months ago and
you guys probably would have bought it
you know the community would have picked
it up it would have been okay book but
that's not enough like I want the book
to change your life if it doesn't change
your life then I wasted my time and I'm
not happy and I think I'm capable of
doing that and I want to go out and
create it and do that for you and so
because I believe that it changes your
mindset when you sit down to create when
I go in front of my laptop and I am
typing up my book I'm in it with the
mindset of I will need to create
something great here as opposed to I'm
just trying to get this done
and so what's the mindset when you come
into whatever you're doing whether
you're making YouTube videos or you're
creating a product you're selling a
service do you come in with the mindset
that you are
do something great that you're trying to
have a big impact or you just kind of
going through the motions you will
accomplish what you feel you are capable
of and as long as you have that limited
mindset you're not going to do something
great so I want to challenge you today
to raise the stakes to raise the
expectations to think that you can do
more to believe that you can do more and
challenge yourself to do more in the
next priority that you take on and do
something right now do something today
to help that move forward just a little
bit so the question of the day today is
what are the bold expectations you have
of yourself leave it in the comments
below I'm curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso